[Music]
what have you encountered in your life
that like a person is doing something
crazy and you're like
holy [ __ ] that person's [ __ ] crazy
i've seen a lot of crazy people
i mean like my mom like every day
like like scary scary crazy where you're
like whoa that that's
just so crazy that this person is insane
that i just don't want them in my life
just the other day on youtube i saw a
guy jump off of a roof
on a bicycle and then he landed on a
flight of stairs and i was like that's
crazy
that is crazy if he landed in your life
safely like he wasn't injured
no wow oh i want him in my life
when i watch parkour like live i also
parkour hardcore parkour hardcore
parkour yeah
why did i say it just parkour okay thank
you
for parkour um when i watch that live i
i can't
like you know when your sphincter just
kind of like yeah intense for them
yeah yeah it's like it's cool but
something about i don't know how to
respond to you as a human being you
follow aaron jamin
the really crazy guy who does all the
instagram stuff he flips like off the
craziest building
yeah yeah yeah like it's like like pure
pull to pure pull to purple that's crazy
clay is it clay it's crazy what would
you would you guys define this
one as crazy um being so heated
at your ex-girlfriend that you think
you're gonna get back at her by grabbing
a hornet's nest squeezing it and eating
it
oh my god that's a different kind of
crazy
that's what the context was i saw the
video oh my god that's a different kind
of crazy
that's stupid i'm gonna play this video
for you guys that wasn't romantic
that's stupid is this some asian [ __ ]
that's a little romantic you tell me
it doesn't sound it's like if poetic was
more like rap
but like bad i don't know here we go
it's the bad boy of romance
oh my god he has to jump to get it too
so he went out of his way
how do you even find that we absolutely
do not know
here we go harnessness hornet's nest
he wanted him [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
is that what you really wanted you sure
about that
oh my god
i like how he has his own soundtrack too
[Music]
oh he didn't even eat it poor hornets
we didn't swallow it yeah there he is
people classify that as eating it
there he is ooh
damn that guy's pretty hardcore he's
[ __ ] jacked parkour he does
the magic trick you know what he did he
grabbed it and he killed all the hornets
first
so they don't sting him i thought he was
just gonna go
and [ __ ] bite it and then they're
inside his mouth going
and [ __ ] stinging his ass and he's
like [ __ ]
and you see a hornet on his tongue and
then he eats it
and then and then his tongue is like
this big hornet though
ever grab the horn so if you grab a
hornet this [ __ ] is like this
already
oh no they bite they'll sting you
grab it this hole will sting you away
from the fingers like this count
with you again
[Laughter]
i got a hornet sting right here you see
this what
that's a hornet sting it's so swollen
wait when did that no i'm just buff
because this isn't regular so
this right here it happened over a week
ago oh like
a week and not a b no because i saw the
[ __ ]
i was out there checking out my figs and
then this [ __ ] just kept
[ __ ] around my leg and i was like get
the hell away from me hornet
and then he just went and i was like oh
[ __ ] and i slapped his ass away
and then he went on my other ankle he
tried to bite me
i just had to [ __ ] do one of those
back kicks and run as fast as i could
then you back kicked the hornet
that is pretty sick at the time pat was
living at my house right so he was
working out in my garage
and i [ __ ] ran through the garage
screaming and he was like what happened
i'm like
i'm [ __ ] getting attacked by a hornet
they repeatedly
you didn't tell him to run too what if
he just he was like oh okay joe and you
run away with all the corners attacking
he used him as a body decoy yeah
no problem man stay out there no it was
just
one it was just one guy i was reading on
them they uh
you can't you're not like bees if
they're chasing after you you can jump
in the water and then they'll
don't go in the water
hornets and wasps they'll just hang out
until you come back out oh my god
they're like your mom like a mom you
know she's keeping your ass
she's like i'mma [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah
yeah i was reading it because i i have a
ton of wasps around my house
why i don't know what kind of like the
yellow jackets like those kinds
i mean they look the same as like the
normal wasp so
like the yellow jacket uh what the
hornets or they watch i think they're
wasps
versus hornets what's the most
discernible feature
the major difference between wasps and
hornets is size and color
hornets are larger wasps have black and
yellow rings while
hornets have black and white wait but
look up
paper wasp compared to yellow jacket
hornet they look exactly the same
yeah and what whatever they are they've
known multiple times
they do they
i don't know because it feels like a
bite it's with the butt it's with the
butt right
here okay we'll do it again what is it
like was it like this
it's like that i thought that fool was
biting me that [ __ ] hurt
[ __ ] with his butt that [ __ ] hurt man
so so they stay much behind so they
don't they don't lodge their stinger and
you like a b does it's pretty close
though
can i see pictures my right calf was
more swollen than my left
leg oh so he got the other one even
though you kicked it no i didn't i
didn't really
pulled up so it's paper wasp versus
yellow jacket
i got [ __ ] up by the paper i got
[ __ ] up by the paperwork
these are fat fat yeah mine was thick
you know just thick bonded i hate that
dude man
definitely was using [ __ ] bug kung fu
on me and [ __ ]
um i didn't i couldn't even find the the
nest either
if i found that nest i would have
destroyed that you would have ate it huh
like this dude that that was pretty
crazy though i'm lucky i've never had
anything like that
am i like i have oh i did have my one of
my sister's
ex-boyfriends my fight my dad but he
wasn't like that
they got a fist fight that's pretty good
one i don't remember i was really young
what if a dad got his ass beat
i don't think he got his ass beat i
remember i don't remember feeling
disappointed
i think it was a perfectly fair fight
actually it came down to a couple
coronas and some steak at the end
and tahin is that what you just said
that's racist
i ended it with some mangoes
that sounds good so yeah so
that video it surfaced on reddit and
it's just captioned with my buddy is a
maniac
dot dot just watch so i don't even know
anything else about this dude it's just
the fact that
this kind of it got a lot of attention
on reddit
he was heartbroken huh so it seems like
it seems like you want to cheat on me
with him will he eat a horn's nest ha
you chose the wrong man
that seems like the logic it really is i
don't know if that's gonna get her back
though
i died at it unless she's like she's
like oh my god
i am with a [ __ ] i made the wrong
choice
unless she's there watching it with her
new boo and she's like
would you do this yeah no i'm leaving
and she's wearing a t-shirt full of a
bunch of hornets it's like her passion
or his passion because he's eating the
hornets this is true those are her pet
hornets
or what if he's like that's child's play
and he goes out to a beehive
and he gets the whole [ __ ] beehive
and he pus puts it over his head
a cartoon yeah that's hot
i'd take him back and he puts it off and
he has bee stings all over his face
damn i know do you guys remember do you
guys remember that one
uh friends episode when he like rachel
and ross had the whole like we were on a
break thing i think it was then
and then there was like this like fat of
yogurt because yogurt was sitting there
right wasn't it yeah drink the fat and
to drink the fat then
she would forgive ross but then he was
like
okay he almost did it she was like but
then she ended up forgiving him but like
that makes me think like what
what extremes would you know someone
actually go through
exactly to try to get someone back
because that's pretty crazy
if he's trying to get her that's not a
get back please that's that look more
like a [ __ ] you yeah it looks like i'm
gonna kill him it sounds like a threat
yeah it's like i'm willing to eat this
hornet's nest so if you bring your new
man around i will bite
his balls off or something yeah it's
like in the movies you know when someone
shoots with a bow and arrow
and the guy goes like this and he just
takes it he just
breaks it oh i'll keep the arrowhead
inside
and they're like because it's healthier
than that well you're supposed to do
that
yeah so it doesn't bleed out yeah but it
just looks it just looks crazy and
you're like
now you got splinters in there i know
you want to make this joke all real
you just want to be like so then you
don't have to walk around with a big
arrow boner but you should because it
looks
cool but the regular person is the
little stuff looks good
oh [ __ ] ah get it out
get it out then when someone gets close
don't touch it
don't touch it no
i wonder if there was anyone like in in
[ __ ]
like a night or or samurai whatever if
they actually reacted that way like
that's the movies man every single time
they're like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] me they got the more
realistic movies now right
right like those ones are like way
better because you just feel like that's
how you would do it
and then afterwards the the hot sword
comes on oh yeah
right i would look around first i'd like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] hates like a
[ __ ]
yeah cause you know expressing
expressing
pain actually helps alleviate it versus
the
bottom yeah and then bottling it up yeah
on uh mythbusters
if you were to curse compared to just
saying random words if you were to curse
it feels better
yeah you can handle more pain yeah
they're down on mythbusters just a
little bit more pain
dang suddenly i feel way more okay to
curse you
oh thank you no no i just i thought we
were headed down the same path
yeah i stopped trying to stop cursing
stop trying to stop so you're still how
long did you try stopping
probably a day when i realized i'm
living a lie
it is hard not until you have kids and
you realize like oh [ __ ] i
[ __ ] cuss a lot and it's still hard
yeah because we're trying not to because
it isn't we
can't reason so we can't be like hey
this is what the parents this is like
adult language
so we can't even reason just yet um so
now he's like the cuss police and he
just
he catches this all the time he could be
in that different store but that's not
what
he's still saying yeah we love it like
which ones are what words can't you say
he goes
you can't say [ __ ] you can't say stupid
you can't say what the hell we're like
again
i could imagine this fool playing
another room exactly like that
oh they [ __ ] it up no no [ __ ]
i have a different like level of like
cursing depending on which group of
friends i'm around
because i have a friend who doesn't
curse at all i have a couple friends who
do not even
curse at all and they're old you know so
like i just
it's not just in their vocabulary yeah
so i just adapt to it
yeah that's true you kind of do adapt to
the people you're around well for me
i don't think i ever curse yeah it just
comes out right and then i watch the
vlog and i'm like
i curse yeah yeah or like a taika points
it out or like someone else points it
out like
oh like a brand deal can you please take
out these bad words i'm like what bad
words i was so good
[ __ ] bad words i just feel like
they're like
really powerful adjectives right
it's like a seller if you want to
emphasize yeah you just you just
it's an accent almost right it's like a
lingo
fancy totally fine
you